And obvious question is why
worry about cyber security?
Actually, before we get into
the cyber side of things,
let's talk about when or
why do we worry about security.
We worry about securing something, or
we worry about the security problem.
When we have something of value, but
there also has to be a threat source
that poses some kind of a risk to it.
So clearly you worry about security
when there's something of value, and
you perceive that there's risk that is
posed to that thing that is of value.
So let's get back to cyber security now.
So let's ask those same questions,
what is of value in
the context of cyber security?
And where do the threats come from?
What kind of risk are we talking about?
Who is the source of the threat?
In terms of what is of value,
all of us store a lot of sensitive data.
If criminals, if they get their
hands onto this sensitive data
that we're talking about, of course
they can monetize it and profit from it.
And it is no exaggeration to say that
societies actually rely on the internet
for really important things.
So these are again critical
resources that we all rely on.
Which could be attractive targets for
our adversaries.
In this case the reasons may be
different from simply profiting from it.
To look at sort of a quick example
of what we just talked about.
In particular our
critical infrastructure.
People talk about smart grids, they're
basically talking about the electric
power generation, distribution, billing,
all the different things that we do
to make sure that we have
electricity when we need it.
If the computer is
controlling the smart grid,
whoever sort of takes control of
those computers, is controlling
a extremely important infrastructure
on which the community relies.
Obviously every business and
government agency now use computers and
networks to carry out what they're
supposed to do their daily activities.
But what happens if hackers,
or adversaries, or
unauthorized parties gain access to it?
So it's an easy argument to make that
cyber security is extremely important.